if you can't save your home
at least you can try and save yourself
kartik's family evacuated on sunday
after intense rain flooded their house
how many people here you how many others
six
six people are living here
and you're staying at the school now
he tells us the water came up five foot
in here
20 centimeters of rain fell in chennai
on sunday
low-lying parts of the city are still
flooded and more rain is coming
this is the fourth day that parts of
chennai have been submerged like this
and it's not just to do with the volume
and the intensity of rain that's been
falling but also because of the way the
city has become so urbanized natural
soakaways have been built over so when
the rain falls like it has been doing
it's simply got nowhere to go
most people in this neighborhood have
already locked their doors and left
but we find one family clinging on to
the last bit of dry space they have
as the water rises around them
bringing filth with it
you can see there the
house was filled by the flat
so they lost the house so they're
suffering lot of so they can't be able
to sleep here and also
how many days they can stay in the
government school
for now help is in the form of food
rations
government teams are still trying to
evacuate the most at risk
at least 10 people so far across the
state have died in these floods and
although officials say the rain so far
isn't as severe as forecast many are
still incredibly vulnerable
cattle river topsy sky news in chennai
india